well tyler malley is a guy that's going
to go out there and compete last time he
pitched against these guys he did okay
and he's just been okay but he can be
so much better
and he gets it from jump
caught looking right on the black it
looked like that fastball right there
surprised colton wong christian yellen
should be the hitter
sends that one to center naked quinn
started in now hops back and makes the
cap two are up to her down and willia
thomas will be the hitter swing gonna
miss struck him out with an elevated
fastball malley strikes out two as part
of a one two three first inning
right-hander adrian hauser back to work
picked up no decision against these reds
last time he towed the slab pitched well
four to third innings gave up three
unearned runs one two pitch
and that hit him
sinker on the inner part of the plate
india who doesn't do much to get out of
the way those pitches on the inner part
of the plate anyway here's jesse winker
now
it's a little chopper over to first
peterson flips to adonis and the return
throw not in time
over to hauser so winker will reach
here's nick castiano's this one's lifted
in the air to shallow left yelich
easily drifting in to make the catch
that's the second out of the inning
winker off second base motto at first
and here's tyler naquin runners go
swings hammers it to right down face hit
green light is on for winker garcia just
now gets to the ball bottom rounds third
naked slows at second he thunders a two
run double into the right field corner
and the reds ahead in ending number one
a two-nothing lead
does a nice job of staying through that
baseball he had that running lead winker
easily is going to score but joy bottom
not far behind him we head to the second
inning two-nothing cincinnati brings up
avi garcia this is hit well in the left
center field deep and gone
avi sahil garcia with a solo shot he
gets the brewers on the
board a hanging slider it did a ton well
he weighed it back nicely on that pitch
a hanger and garcia banged it out of
here pitcher's best friend for adrian
hauser colton wong back in there the one
two
swing and a miss split finger runs down
and away and well over the top of it is
wong one down and now here's christian
yelich
ground in
suarez nice pick running throw in todd
well that's a nice play gino showing the
athleticism you saw farmer go behind
avoid the collision allow gino to make
the play we go to the bottom of three
two on reds castiano's first at bat a
fly ball into very shallow left
and that hits castellanos that ball was
nowhere near
the strike zone and nick is unhappy
he turns to the brewer dugout and says
hey that ball hit me on my back arm up
and in and now the reds with first and
second and just one away for eugenio
suarez there it is and he smokes it over
the head of yellet one hops the wall
here comes castellanos he will score and
here comes naked right in his back
pocket he's safe four to one reds how
about that
tyler naquin was on his horse scoring
all the way from first base and he
smokes it off the base of the left field
wall over the head of christian yelling
friends have pushed their lead to four
to one but we will hold our breath a
little bit aristide's aquino is in right
field taking over for nick costianos who
got hit by a pitch in that last inning
and you hope and pray he's okay
to garcia knocked in the only brewers
run
and a swing and a miss he pumped a
fastball by him up and out of the zone
and garcia is down on strikes maui's
fifth strike out of the game kesten era
stands in the hit adrian hauser is done
goes up for seamer swinging a miss
six k's for tyler mallet that
combination that high fastball up in the
zone you see it so close to your eyes
you think you could catch up to it wong
reaches for the first time today brewers
have a base runner ahead of christian
yelich
bring them up
strike three at seven k's for tyler
mallett so now willie adams bats and he
lines one towards right aquino back
warning track it is gone
a home run for willie adamus into the
front row of seats
just to the left of the brewers bullpen
the brewers are right back in in a
one-run game it's 4-3
just over the yellow line
fan reaching in
and trying to make the catch he dropped
it but that ball was over the yellow
line for a two-run home run for willie
adamus
the brewers are right back in it here's
narvaez
swing to the miss struck him out got him
in the fast ball away norvaez is down on
strikes mali has eight of them tonight
two out error opened the door naked went
up to second tucker barnhart duo
first pitch swinging right center base
hit naked given the wave throw goes
toward third naked scores get down slide
safe suarez first to third and tucker
barnhart delivers again five three rings
third walk issued by mali here comes
luis orios
lines one fair and that's going to head
to the corner running it down is winker
rounding third is peterson heading home
and it's back to a one-run game in
cincinnati rbi double for luis arias
he's come up with some big hits as well
and guess who he drives in jayce
peterson who walked tying run and
scoring position now they leaves in line
for the win enter a.g
there's jbj with a high chopper and it's
off the glove
of
j of india and rounding third and
scoring is uris and this game is tied at
five india was thinking about throwing
to first base before he had the ball in
his glove it hit off the tip of his
glove went into center field
and we are even go ahead run out there
at second wong trying to come up with a
big hit swinging a base hit into left
field jackie bradley jr is going to be
sent around third the ball gets away
from winker the brewers take the lead
6-5 on our unscoring single from colton
long it's a three-run sixth inning for
the brew crew brings up luis maria so
runs scoring double back in the sixth
as
sends one in the air deep to left field
winker going back looking up and it's
gone a pitch off the outside corner and
urias turned on it
and sends it out of here
that ball just kept on carrying in the
cincinnati air
and the brewers
up by a pair so no official word from
the reds on nick castianos who left this
game after being hit by a pitch but he
just re-emerged in the dugout he does
not have a brace on he was motioning to
players in the dugout where the baseball
hit him and actually went through a
swinging motion again no official word
from the reds but the fact that he's out
here i hope is a good sign seven five
brewers with the bases loaded now
they've got a chance to really break it
open if adamus can come up with a big
hit
and there's a shot into left field deep
it is off the wall
running it down as wanker
wong is in they had to hold up yelich
over to third two runs are in
wong and jackie bradley jr
as the brewers start to break it open
here in the eighth
gotta love it now william dom is having
a big day three hits
four runs batted in so now omar narvaez
hits and a wave and a miss ball gets
away from barnhart he can't find it a
run is going to score narvaez will reach
trying to score now from second base and
doing it is adamus
and up to second goes omar narvaez
did that ball get out of play
tim timmons the home point umpire saying
that the ball got out of play and craig
council is holding up the play right now
saying no no it hit off the facing
of that camera well we should have two
runs across when underneath it did go
out of play so it's a wild pitch
allowing a run to score adamus back to
third and avi garcia is the hitter as
that gets by barnard and now what thomas
is in there you go
and on to second goes narvaez it's an
11-5 game zooming her out for aristides
aquinos
aquino shoots with a deep right center
field and the punisher pounds a home run
it's the reds another score his fifth
ladder walked and scored in the first
inning he's been quiet since
[Applause]
yelich is there and the brewers take the
opener another come-from-behind win for
the milwaukee brewers tonight